[Musik]
denn
euro
[Musik]
für zutage jugendlicher ist es so wenn
du kannst zum beispiel dann öffnet so
coole das gefühl vor zögerlichkeit die
derben profitiert hat sich die junge
elite zu tage mein name ist bond
studieren.de zb aus junior software
developer den reseller und verkauf alles
en suite hand rund hauptsächlich für
schuhe
aber ich mache das mit uhr mit wasser
mit kleider mit accessoires alles
mögliche also überall wo nicht gesehen
marica traf etienne das probiere mit
steinen das absurde bis jetzt kann ich
mit gutem gewissen sagen dass ochs ist
der virtual hat mit es was gebracht bzw
flasche war selber designt hat die hat
man für zwei franken ins kino kam sie
nach für 40 ich habe schon immer ein
flair für den handel erst der anfang mit
afrika durchlaufen sie braucht einfach
auf die ca
und dann irgendwann in 2011 bin ich zu
haus nico
[Musik]
kanye wests vorhanden für 200 andere
sachen kaufen jetzt haben wir ein so
schwieriges der sc steht jetzt zwei bis
drei musiker dann mach ja sobald man so
ein gerät für unter 250 eigentlich
ziemlich schnell weg
der virtual bloß die seine vorfreude
mittlerweile ist auch der erste schwarze
wo dieses kolonie vito und der hat jetzt
mit momentum die tram wieder erwähnt der
wirtschaft kurz abfangen und die ktq
academicus abzocke
es macht dich war für mich speziell wird
es ist der designer vor dem schulhof
unterschied jetzt ziemlich viel an den
personen sagen
natalie rickli wird auf unterschiede
hätte jetzt wird so viel wert und wenn
ihr jetzt irgendeiner höhle mit zattoo
sich franco beatles kamen verkauf findet
halt ich wünsche euch und reiter das
erlebnis mit designer zusammen teilt und
sie ich glaube mitglied beste sims
nikodemus tanz
dabei spürte nur die limitierte schuh
abonniert hat und wann limitiert die
stadt alle 40 oder du halt irgendwas tun
verantworten
und jeder versucht
ob es besser ist anders in die thermen
profiliert sich die junge leute zu tag
[Musik]
freundlich so sieht war stich wirklich
das stück auf der internet nicht nur
klavier und leads kontinuität und hierzu
tat ist so wenn du halt richtige
instagram pages folgt hier der tech data
was im haifisch die nächste release wo
gerade im winter gestartet kommentar
mitglied abgrund dazu irgendein star hat
ja mit ticket grades wenn es unbedingt
kaufen und wird auch besseres angebot
gerade so treiben statt
[Musik]
also im prinzip wie reseller
funktioniert ist noch weit
auf alten markt mit nike hirschberg
kollaborationen hat und der hand jetzt
im schuh online herum aus irgendeinem
grund informationen vorher über oder wie
klug schnell und traum von mir schluss
antike 220 franken
die show und nicht länger kontrolliere
alles versaut hat der schule natürlich
verarbeitet worden ist dann wirklich
größere übereinstimmen
jetzt zum beispiel an der ems vor nike
und objekt und deutlich ihnen dann
gesagt mir gekauft worden ist oder markt
ist das genaue modell dann natürlich
großen us- dann zustand der es heißt das
stück das so ganz neu ist eine andere
kondition hat und natürlich nur 28
herschieben
dann habe ich natürlich die hauspreise
wieder im schul und 220 franken
umgerechnet und am schluss geben was der
potenziell die resale wert so würde sie
das war jetzt mit einem schuhe um die
2100 rang vor meistens nicht über den
tisch kommt auf dem graumarkt für die
jetzt sagen media hauptsächlich bildet
sind diese politik und durstig sind und
zum anderen ist nicht vermessen
[Musik]
außerdem bringen
das ist nicht das organ ist jedes
möglichst von skechers nico interessiert
das aber das niveau ist dieser spende
gerne die als lieferstopps verschnitt
gesucht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das ist sicher dass ich darüber der
servicekraft hat für folge dieses zu
sich
diese neigen wir hatten sieben stunden
oder sogar sehr mit dem bus zur schule
[Musik]
ich bin hier netto begleichen hier netto
begleichen at the wheel it wirtschaft
ausgebildet
[Musik]
klar dass ich da
im hobbit zur sorge tag stellen bei der
statement damit setze also handschuhe
ganz zerstört finden durch die seiten
für die stärke des marktes zerstören
sagt wenige fragen also die ganze
nachhaltigkeit geschäft der ezb dar denn
es gibt trends zusammen was auch pluto
langsam frage ich wollte eigentlich nur
das individuum ist beschädigt dadurch
große verein will ich jetzt mache klar
im laufe aber dass man so wirkungsgrad
von politik vor der großen trends der
film stellt heute die rechte knie
es ist zwar gut für mich das lied viel
geld für oskar weselsky ich selber
einkaufen aber verkaufen was ich jetzt
noch dauern weil der jordan vor travis
scott der davis cup ist ein us
amerikanischer rapper für unternehmens
krank und sehr limitiert und römischer
bab 2 musik bis 20 uhr hanni misslich
von clavister die sind nur in amerika so
und dementsprechend limitiert und
natürlich dollar drin
[Musik]
denn die papier noch mehr
übergehen
ltd
die baufirmen
the players said today
wir sind wieder vereint worte sagen sie
waren damit aber im anderen sind auch
christa sagawe sie sich nicht machen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
vielleicht muss man leider nichts kein
messnetz mit nicht grundsätzlich stehe
ich mit der doppelten schnecke als
klosterhof
[Musik]
twitter-nutzer so zeige einfach den
moment ist
die konsumgesellschaft ist abnormal hart
zur sache natürlich braucht alters zu
der frage wo kann ich leide unter wasser
hat ja alles also muss alles hinter
freizeit und nicht nur das was mach ich
möchte einfach die gesellschaft gliedert
ich möchte natürlich meinen beitrag dazu
leistet dass sie bald verbessert
aber ich kann keine idee wie man das und
andere
du hast nicht natürlich viele gedanken
[Musik]
kann man vor zwei jahren als limit
gesetzt und ich zeit habe kann schon
mehr wo mehr als 500 gramm gekostet das
habe ich einmal bronze und meine teams
nickel aber seit zwei jahren bin ich
clean